now I believe this question ma'am as
I've mentioned before as an extension
one question good morning they provide
you suggested substitution yeah people
who have done this question already now
for those of you who haven't seen it yet
and to flex your extension to muscles a
little bit I want you to have a look and
think about what might be a plausible
thing to substitute if you didn't know
what it was now what should you remember
because it's precious memory I showed
you this one last week and the suggested
substitution in that case was 3 sine
theta ok wait the 3 come from obvious
questions Square debate okay so clearly
I'm gonna have to match up with this
bike young so that's that's your a
square right so if you had spirit of
math you'll get 9 minus 9 times minutes
okay so that's ways a three control wife
sighing why do we choose that yeah
okay number one sign is we know lots
about the calculus of simple trig
functions as opposed to you know this
doesn't fit you to the chain rule being
resolved or investigation or anything
but there's a particular thing that's
not just nice about like the calculus
and trig functions but the particular
algebraic arranger you that makes sign
of really meeting each other
if it's a virus better science
yeah yeah very good so the idea here is
if I end up candy I won't worry about
that aggression for now but if what I
end up getting under here is this right
the reason why this is useful to me is
because I can take advantage of that I
do remember that so if you know excuse
me the sine squared plus cos squared is
equal to one then you can take either of
these guys over to the right hand side
and then you can kind of almost
interchange between like get rid of
science pants replacing their the cost
squared so you might recall that you
take your factor of the square root of 9
at the front and then at least you with
1 minus sine squared which is kind of
squares which you still have the woods
yet remember we had a look at that
absolute value thing and we're gonna
address that again today in a different
way but look like this ends up much
simpler and then you can carry on now we
have something different underneath the
square root
that X because X
say you guys have changed yeah sure okay
um why not I wanna with a reason why we
don't do that is because if I said is
yeah I start to come up with all kinds
of toronto's right what I'm doing here
like what I do not tell you is this
what's this do
this is introducing a new variable right
which is fine because like with
integration we've seen it's a dummy
version it's only standing in for a
nutball okay so okay I'm just going to
stand in for a different and that's fine
but the second you said is it's just
saying something quite dramatically
different is it them this is introducing
actually that's an equation which has
certain solutions to it I guess so -
wait
he's gonna I'm not sure at the top check
there it is one more two solutions all
right
in other words this is now staying
actually I want a particular X rather
than no look here I want a whole range
of X's right so this also then
complicates a point I for a chair yes
hey there's a reason why I become
physical because this is unfortunately
it's invasion which has a message so if
you're wondering why I introduced more
variables because introducing less
variables is all right so since has
insisted in this case then - is the man
so I can't take advantage of that
there's a plus right so that the the way
to incorporate that plus is to divide
everything through by in this case plus
squared right if I do that I end up in
tan squared plus one equals
I'm cool now this again I can deal with
right that thing underneath the square
root
it's gonna be this sum of the squared
sum go ahead so that's what suggests to
me I should try something to determine
which is indeed what the um well the
textbook actually yesterday they say
this so you can carry with me
if this is what we're talking with and
again the three comes from exactly the
same place at the same point in this
case okay I'm going to start marching
through this if I know this they're all
of these and I need to start replacing
things in the function but then I need
to take care of the variable of
integration what am i intimating readers
family so how do I do that again
GX a Beefeater right you guys notice we
got so used to differentiating with
respect to X but that's because X is
usually usually our function X right
this is a lot of fun for that it's a
function of you know so that's why I'm
differentiating with respect to that
what is the derivative of technical
things
yeah sec square now this is not um this
derivative is not in the form that I
wanted which is useful for me over here
what point do I want to do yeah I want
to theater of DX to appear in here
because there that I'm DX and this DX
will cancel which is what changes the
variable for me so you can do it a
couple of points I'm gonna do it took
away from what I've done before I'm
gonna divide both sides by DX 1 D theta
that make sense what am I going to get
on the left-hand side I divide that and
it'd just be 1 and we know why what is
your shortcut I can put it anywhere I
like
and when I divide by this you just get
their reciprocal on the right
inside
like so make sense alright so now I'm
ready I can do all the substitutions but
because this is a little more involved
like I've got more stuff over here
versus over here okay I'm gonna do a
couple more steps than I usually do okay
just so I don't screw this up let's do
the normal substitution eyes so I've got
the integral for one over what's the
first thing don't skip any computer
yeah question so I let's just rewind
before I do this cuz really wonder waste
what am I going from this line to this
line I've divided both sides by this
right divided both sides by this
so therefore this thing hasn't done he
hasn't moved anywhere right it's still
three six where Tina and I'm going to
substitute this whole thing in like I'm
gonna imagine evil isn't one I'll put it
in there okay in place of that yeah
because you're substituting DX on D
theta and the DX is third cancel which
is everyone all right so that's why you
turn it back upside down it's a bit
confusing when you're dealing with all
these reciprocal identities which is why
I suggested he's one easier focus on
what you want to get rid of which is the
DX all right and in fact this guy just
kind of comfortable
okay so sorry where were we I'm stop
shooting exiting here right so this is
going to become at the front square
eight nine ten sweat and it looks like
my fraction it's not couldn't big enough
what do I have here this is the same
thing right nine plus okay
so if I was so good
taking care of the function hoarsely
it's now what say yeah yeah okay so I
can do some can see me up there but
before I do that always slide is not
even finished yet
yeah so I need you to deal with this DX
using this guy okay so just gonna suck
the whole thing in its gonna become
three six square theta DB upon DX and
then there's the debts that was there to
begin with and that's what makes my
cancel cancel cancel how does it look
3/6 okay so you're looking at the next
thing
yeah actually make sure this light is
right is this light right yes you're
happy with it now it's a like a sense a
bit of a mess look how much stuff we've
got flying around so take care let's do
one step at a time
I'm sorry it's mr. just a couple times
these let's deal with these guys right
so there are some clusters which I can
simplify what lens over here okay there
is also a three here isn't there it's
the square root of nine so I'm going to
take both of those guys out the front
you came with that three here and is at
three keys so that leaves me with this
at the front okay and what am I gonna
have here I'll put this guy on top
because he doesn't need to be over there
okay so far so good you they will
already gone up to the next step that's
that's fine you can see I'm totally
doing this quite slowly because there's
all kinds of things that are getting
canceled here and I don't want to [ __ ]
him up okay right where am I going to go
next suggestions
okay good so I'm going to leave this guy
on the top this guy here this is SEC
squared
underneath the square root which we've
established earlier
now I can go one more step before I have
to deal with the square root and then I
have no choice I've got a resultant okay
what else could
what are these guys what are they like
their birth identities right
what'swhat's this actually stateful it's
one on one on cos square I mean I could
replace it with 1 plus K to it but that
ends up to make it means Messier not
easier so this is one cos squared right
so really him being on the numerator
really means there's a cos square of the
denominator do you agree with that but
what's 10 squared its sine squared on
cos squared yeah so there's a cos square
and there's a division by cos square
they're both on the denominator okay so
I'm gonna cancel both of them
what are we going at 9:01 Oh boss so
when the course wins cancelled they
leave behind the sign squid on the
genomic DNA map so sine squared and then
you still got this guy
okay